nous sommes le 21 novembre 1917 dans
toute la grande bretagne
les cloches sonnent après trois
terribles années de guerre il y avait
enfin une victoire évidente rapide
important qu'ils aient remporté à moins
d'autres
la troisième armée britannique avait
réussi à percer les lignes allemandes
sur une profondeur de 8 km et elle avait
fait dix mille prisonniers
mais les cloches célébré un peu plus que
ce qui apparaissait comme la première
victoire
on
elle célébrait le triomphe du chat qui
venait de gagner sa première bataille
le char se révéla une formidable arme
psychologique qui terrifiait les années
pour la première fois il fut utilisé en
nombre c'est l'armée britannique fut
enfin en mesure de pénétrer ligne
limitent ce dont elle avait rêvé pendant
la bataille de la somme
après deux ans de combat les soldats sur
le front de l'ouest ont si bien que les
populations civiles avaient besoin d'un
regain de moral après deux ans de guerre
de tranchées des pertes très lourd et
l'énorme sacrifice
le char était ce un signe d'espoir et la
bataille de cambrai propre et animateurs
et puis la tacc tourna court et patina
pendant des jours les allemands
lancèrent une incroyable contre attaque
les britanniques perdirent 6000
prisonniers et tout le terrain conquis
depuis le premier jour où tous se
demandaient si la bataille de cambrai a
été un succès pour les britanniques
alors quoi que la bataille de cordeau et
le succès d'un jour après quoi elle sut
comme toutes les autres bataille
terrible désastre avec des pertes de
chaque côté
cambrai l'un des grands espoirs déçus de
la première guerre mondiale
chaque camp et son jour de gloire
mais chaque camp fut incapable de durée
et d'exploiter sa victoire
ce fut aussi une bataille curieuse les
britanniques se sont lancés les premiers
il venait d'achever une longue et
épuisante campagne à passchendaele avec
un quart de million d'hommes perdu
l'ensemble de l'armée avait besoin de
repos et pas d'une autre offensive médoc
said
le commandant en chef de l'armée
britannique subissait des pressions
quelques jours plus tôt le premier
ministre david lloyd george avait
publiquement exprimé sa frustration et
celle de son cabinet à propos des
attaques jugé futile deux aides dans la
somme et apache modèle edge avait grand
besoin d'une victoire pour sauver sa
place et la nation en avait également
besoin est que savait que sa carrière
était en jeu lloyd george en avait après
lui il avait besoin de toi pas forcément
d'une robe noire mais il ferait sonner
les cloches passe dans toutes les
églises dans la tête l'autre pression
serait devenait de certains de ses
officiers qui pensaient détenir la clé
du succès face aux allemands et
attendait désespérément une occasion de
l'essayer il voulait jouer sur la
surprise avec de nouvelles tactiques
d'artillerie et avec les chars la
surprise est décisif pour vaincre tout
le monde savait cela mais pour que
l'infanterie pénètre les champs de
barbelés défendu par lénine
mitrailleuses il fallait une semaine
entière de pilonnages d'artillerie ce
qui rendait toute surprise impossible
à la fin 2009 117 les artisans étaient
devenus capables de placer des coups sur
des objectifs précis sentir de réglage
préalable
les canons étaient près réglé donc si
les batteries étaient discrètement
acheminées sur zone de nuit est caché
elle pourrait ouvrir le feu avec une
surprise totale
restait encore le problème des barbelés
qu'un bombardement de quelques heures ne
pourrait supprimer et la ligne
hindenburg était profonde de 45 à 90 m
pour y faire face une nouvelle arme
avait été développé le char
pesant plus de 28 tonnes cet engin était
en mesure d'ouvrir des brèches à travers
les barbelés général et barbelés n'était
pas un problème pour les chars qui font
monter à travers et les aplatissait
littéralement ce qui permettait à la
fonderie de suivre sans doute il
ralentissait légèrement levé le pied
mais y passer sans aucun problème les
canons de s'y livrer les lloris avait
été conçu pour détruire les nids de
mitrailleuses qui avait décimé tant de
soldats britanniques
le canon était un câble 55 mm nous
l'appelions civile dans l'armée
britannique
une s'exprimait avec le système de
nelson à propos des canons il était en
réalité destiné à traiter d'abord ce que
nous désignons comme des cibles en dur
le plus souvent des black house et
véhicules ce genre de cibles n'étaient
que très peu présents sont le monde vous
pouvez tirer les obus explosifs des
positions trop fait ou dit mitrailleuse
suit mais contre les cibles humaines
les mitrailleuses présence sur les chars
étaient nettement plus efficace
ces nouvelles tactiques d'artillerie
alliés aux chars rendait la surprise
possible et peut être aussi la victoire
de très nombreuses personnes contribuer
à développer le char le personnage le
plus influent d'entre eux ne fut autre
que winston churchill lui même ce que
oui ici elle tout premier choix il veut
baptisée little louie une référence
irrespectueux qu'est ce qui le rend
incroyable historique c'est qu'il fut
développée par l'amirauté britannique
l'armée terre n'a rien à voir avec une
seule churchill premier lord de
l'amirauté à ce moment là rongé son
frein en voyant ce que le tour que
prenait la guerre en france car il était
convaincu qu'ils avaient de meilleurs
moyens de mener le combat
il provoque à son directeur des
chantiers navals avec une équipe
d'ingénieurs en leur demandant de
trouver une solution
et voici six sorties cette période de
recherche
quand des prospectives des chars et les
armes initial et était effectivement des
armes de l'année churchill la marine ont
furent les pionniers chips vous avez été
développé en tant qu engins de
débarquement mais très vite leur
potentiel fut reconnue par tous ceux qui
avaient la tête sur les épaules et
l'armée est rapidement les choses en
main après de nombreuses conversations
avec les gens qui voulaient régler le
problème des tranchées le prototype le
plus abouti sur le modèle de production
du premier lot de chars le mark 1
le char était consommée pour avoir la
meilleure mobilité personnes en tout
terrain avant toute autre qualité
j'ai pour toi les chenilles sont aussi
intérieurement on fait le char et
littérale a pris en sandwich entre à ses
deux chevilles
contrairement aux charmes l'air le
compartiment reste au dessus du train de
roulement
tout ça pour une vitesse maximale de
tête kilomètre et demi à l'heure dans
les bons jours
un engin très rudimentaire mais très
robuste
un petit nombre de chars avaient déjà
été engagés dans la bataille de la somme
en septembre 1916 un nombre un peu plus
important essayer de surmonter
l'enlisement de passchendaele l'année
suivante
dans aucune de ces batailles ne
rencontrèrent un réel succès mais à
l'automne 1917 il est temps qu'ils
savaient pourquoi les chars devaient
être utilisés en grand nombre sur un sol
dur et si possible par surprise
5917 les partisans des tang se faisait
entendre de plus en plus les chars
étaient engagés en nombre depuis
maintenant un an
mais il n'avait pas fait parler d'eux au
sein de la cavalerie de nombreux plans
furent échafaudé et après la bataille de
passchendaele ce fut l'un d'entre eux un
raid blindé à grande échelle sur cambrai
qui retint l'attention de m
l'opportunité fut donnée à la cavalerie
le plan initial leur demander d'attaquer
saint quentin par une petite opération
s'introduire détruire et repartir
modifié pour devenir une véritable
percée après cette fameuse paire séries
font que l'on attendait depuis 1914
allait enfin être tenté ici
tout avait été prévu comme pour une
offensive majeure
elle devait éventré les lieux allemand
permettant à la cavalerie d'exploiter la
situation et obligeant les allemands à
se replier en masse la bataille de
cambrai ex jurée allemand issu de la
volonté des règles de calmer les
pressions des politiques après la somme
en 1916 et arrache un prêt pass haendel
en 1917 réclamait une victoire que aig
ne semblait pas être en mesure de
remporter
c'est ainsi que a mis sur pied le plan
de la bataille de cambrai pour faire
bouger à nouveau l'enfant de la zone
choisie pour l'attaqué était une bande
de huit kilomètres d'herbe au sud du
champ de bataille de la somme
juste devant cambrai alors occupée par
les allemands
le sol était dur il n'y avait pas de
débris et autres éclats des précédents
combats il était porté des deux côtés
par deux canaux parallèles distant de 8
à 10 km
bien que le canal de gauche soit à sec
ils constituaient tous les deux des
obstacles considérables ce qui
sécurisaient les flancs de l'opération
les défenses allemandes étaient fixés
très fortifiée complétant le nouveau
dispositif et nous devons y croit ligne
de trancher séparer de 3 5 km auxquels
se rajoutent et une 4e devant cambrai
les tranchées et est élargie de quatre
mètres alors sommé ce qui les rendait
infranchissable par les chars ils
élargissement par les allemands de leur
tranchée à qu'andré et les nouveaux
projectiles anti charles développé
l'année prochaine a révélé que les
allemands pensaient que les sharks
je vais avoir un impact massif sur le
champ de bataille en a partout faire
en données sous notre corps le canal du
nord et en 1917 est il à sec
encore une construction à me voir des
traces de remblais et vont blé dont les
sapeurs allemands profitèrent retranché
après l'avoir orienté y avoir creuser
des galeries ils renversèrent de bunker
en béton avec des postes d'observation
et des réseaux de tranchées qui
recouvrait les défenses principal du
côté de la zone à partir de laquelle les
britanniques étaient censés attaque
cependant la fortification de ses
défenses signifiait aussi qu'elles
n'étaient pas tenus par de gros
effectifs
seuls trois faible division était au
repos dans ce que les allemands appelés
le sanatorium des flandres défendu par à
peine 34 canon les britanniques eux
prévoyaient d'attaquer avec 474 chars
1003 canon et cette division
d'infanterie plus cinq divisions
cavalerie supplémenté apprête à
s'engouffrer dans la brèche
une fois l'infanterie et les chars
introduit dans les positions allemandes
ne devions envoyer la cavalerie comme à
la chasse poursuivant les nuits de la
profondeur et bien sûr ne pouvez pas
affronter le moindre barbelés alors nous
avions prévu des huit chars spécialement
entraîné équipé ses grappes un artiste
qui devait a tranché les barbelés mais
replier et est coupée lorsque ces gros
fils de barbelés été tiré dans deux
directions différentes cartes de char
détruit cassé et on pouvait créer un
passage suffisamment large pour faire
passer un réveillon camaret en c
à cause des pertes suivie à
passchendaele les britanniques n'avait
plus guère de réserves des actifs à
cambrai seulement trois divisions et
l'expérience leur avait montré que les
troupes fraîches étaient nécessaires
pour maintenir la pression d'une attaque
pour les chars il n'y avait pas de
réserver tout le monde devait y aller le
premier jour
l'esa qui ferait du dit a également une
attaque sur un fond réduit à peine la
moitié de la somme
or les attaques sur des fonds et trois
étaient plus faciles à repousser bien
que les canaux permettent de protéger
les flancs l'un d'entre eux ou les deux
devraient tout de même être franchie
pour mener l'attaqué ce qui voulait dire
qu'il fallait prendre les peaux intacte
autre chose le choix du champ de
bataille de cambrai plus excellents pour
différentes raisons mais j'étais la
topographie très plane car le solde de
cambrai n'avait pas été pilonnée par
l'artillerie
une autre bonne raison était la présence
des deux canaux qui protégerait la
progression des britanniques où il a été
le canal du nord et l'autre à l'est
était le canal de saint-quentin
les canes ont constitué des barrières
naturelles sur les extrémités du fonds
et les généraux et ses airs à cet
endroit qui comportait les obstacles
majeurs de placer des divisions d'élite
leur meilleure unité d'attaqué pour
essayer de prendre et de tenir coi clé
la préparation de l'attaqué elle même
fut méticuleuse les officiers présents
dans la zone porter des lunettes et de
longs manteaux pour dissimuler leur
identité de fausses rumeurs feu répandus
et les chars et cano a mené son zone de
nuit dans les jours précédant la
bataille de grosses préparations eurent
lieu milliers d'obus d'artillerie de
soldats et toute l'infrastructure
requise pour lancer six chars en avant
des remises en place et ensuite à la
dernière minute ses chars eux-mêmes
arrivèrent sur le champ de bataille il
devait arriver de nuit leur moteur
tournant au minimum il ya une vitesse
autorisée de 800 mètres par peur une
fois en position il fut recouvert de
tissu de camouflage pas ressembler à des
pierres et des briques et camouflet à
l'écart rien que pour les chars 5
millions de cartouches 500 milles au vu
de si lille est plus de 750 mille litres
de carburant huile et de grèce furent
acheminées camoufler les chars les plus
obsolètes devrait être utilisée pour
ravitailler les chars d'attac sur le
champ de bataille lui même pour franchir
les tranchées chaque char transportait
une phase in de 1 mètre 80 ou des fagots
de bois attachée par de grosses chaînes
et qui pesait une tonne et demie environ
les chars avancerez par trois en flèche
et un chaque tranche est le premier
déposerait sa phase in permettant au
groupe de passer
l'infanterie elles avaient ordre de
rester collé au char en appui mutuelle
les chars étaient là au cas où
l'infanterie rencontrerait des tirs de
mitrailleuses lourdes ou des troupes
ennemies et les fantassins devait
protéger les chars pendant leur a soif
laitière où il allait faire face
notamment à des unités d'artillerie très
déterminé
1 6 heures 20 le matin du 20 novembre un
millier de canaux britannique ouvrit
soudainement le feu les allemands ne s'y
attendait pas du tout ils furent
totalement surpris par ce déluge d'obus
explosifs de fumigènes et de gaz c'est
ainsi qu'il vire à avancer dans la brume
de l'aurore des milliers dhombres
gigantesque qui avançaient lentement
vers eux arrachant les barbelés et leurs
mitrailleuses faisant feu de toutes
parts
c'en était trop et les allemands se
rendirent par centaines les quelques-uns
qui continuèrent à se battre moururent
suit l'avancée des chars et l'infanterie
anglaise pas ça par dessus les barbelés
aplatit pour sauter dans les tranchées
à 8 heures alors que le soleil se levait
chargé troupes à pied qui est une pause
pour contempler ce surprenant succès
avec très peu de perte est guère de
difficultés ils s'étaient rendus maîtres
de la ligne ndongo et de ses premières
tranchées il était maintenant prêt à
attaquer la troisième tranche et la
ligne de ravitaillement qui devaient
être prises pour atteindre les deux
objectifs de la journée sur la gauche il
y avait le bois boorlo qui bloquait
l'arrivée de la cavalerie par le nord
sur la droite se trouvaient les villages
marcoing et manière avec deux points
vitaux sur le canal de saint-quentin se
rendre maître de ses peaux était vitale
tant que la cavalerie franchissent le
canal et entre d'encombrés sur les
arrières de l'ennemi
à midi était presque juste derrière la
troisième y a 5 ou 6 km de cambrai là où
la population française sortait dans les
rues en attendant la libération
simple fait d'avoir percé en ligne et
d'une banque réputée imprenable
constitué déjà une victoire en soi sauf
les chars et l'infanterie travaillant de
concert les allemands battaient en
retraite non au commandant cherchait
encore à comprendre ce qui s'était passé
et c'est alors que sur vingt deux des
aspres aux erreurs du commandement
afrique hier nous allons voir maintenant
comment c'est plus largement de chaque
côté ce qui fut l'une des pistes
majeures le premier jour de la bataille
de cambrai l'une des divisions
britannique sur le centre gauche de
l'avancé était le 50e island commandée
par le général george rappeur harper ne
se souciait pas des tanks et n'attendit
pas les 70 chars qui lui étaient
attribués alors il donne alors
d'attaquer droit devant avec ce qu'il
appelle ses petits gars 200 m derrière
des arbustes
concernant la coopération des chars et
d'infanterie n'était pas oubliée jour
sur les champs de bataille de 1917 il
était assez sceptique à propos de ce
fait les chars pouvait réellement il
craignait de classe et son axe entre
autres auprès des stars qui a tiré le
feu il autorisera également ses troupes
à attendre une heure après avoir pris la
lignée d'hommes beau au lieu de repartir
au combat immédiatement le résultat fut
que lorsque ses troupes tirent mouvement
vers leurs objectifs suivants le village
et le vallon de fléquières les allemands
avaient eu le temps de se retrancher
dans le village est d'amener leur as
tiré le problème est que même si les
chairs arrivé à neutraliser les barbelés
la vente y ait des six mois derrière
qu'elle n'arrivait pas à trouver les
vrais pour passer et cela me surprend ce
cas on peut voir ici car il trace de
chair
et je ne comprends pas comment ils n'ont
pas pu les suivre les chars ont ensuite
gravi une colline et se sont fait ce
cahier en pièce à part un par une
batterie allemande qu'il est important
d'ajouter c'est que le 19 à 20 coups
plusieurs soldats britanniques avaient
été faits prisonniers
certains d'entre eux avaient parlé d'une
attaque de charge des pierres c'est que
c'est un droit que les allemands se
concentrèrent leur art lyrique commandé
par généralement waters et chez les
grands comptes ont érigé l'artilleur a
combattu lundi les chars britannique
bien en avant leur infanterie furent
détruits par ces pièces des tirs répétés
1016 chat hors de combat en 20 minutes
après que les chars et été rapatriés
vers l'arrière les highlanders de
repartir pour coin de village mais de
pure avancé étant que ce village était
tenu par les allemands les unités
situées sur le flanc gauche des riders
devait stopper leur avance dans le bois
de bourlon juste avant la campagne
entourant cambrai au premier jour de
leur attaque il n'y avait pas un
allemand dans le bois mais la nuit
suivante les allemands firent mouvement
et après cinq jours de violents combats
des britanniques ne purent jamais le
pont de balmont
c'est que le recul je pense que harper a
servi de skinny sert pour la bataille de
cambrai nouvelles technologies il était
conscient des fortes pertes que tu
pouvais te questionner le fait d'exposer
des hommes a découvert sous le feu des
oignons souhaitait sûrement pas laisser
vos gars trop près des champs et
l'histoire aime les moutons noirs
avec tout le respect que je lui dois je
pense qu'un père et deux nuls à d'autres
là pendant ce temps une erreur d'un
autre ordre était en train de se
produire sur le flanc droit du champ de
bataille en début d'après-midi les chars
britannique avait atteint marcoing et
son pont sur le canal est occupée
manière bien que ce principe soit
détruit
les britanniques tenez par ailleurs
plusieurs petits ponts à pied de même
que le pan de marcoing il ne restait à
la cavalerie qui a foncé à travers la
brèche et pendant les allemands par
l'arrière mais cela n'arrivera pas
le général kavanagh qui commandait la
cavalerie s'était placé avec ses troupes
loin derrière la première ligne a faim
il avait de très bonne communication
avec son supérieur le général bing qui
commandait la troisième armée mais la
liaison vers le front elle était très
mauvaise en conséquence ils n'ont reçu
des nouvelles de la percée que plusieurs
heures après et lorsque les cavaliers
arrivèrent sur le canal il était 3
heures de l'après midi
un escadron du cannet john roos ford à
peine 120 tonnes traversa et s'enfonça
dans le crépuscule les survivants revint
vers les ennemis le lendemain ayant
perdu tous leurs chevaux et les deux
tiers de leurs effectifs
le reste de la cavalerie cinq divisions
retourne à son campement pour nourrir et
faire boire les chevaux il ne
participait pas au combat de ce jour
l'idée de ce que l'on aurait pu
accomplir notre attaque aurait fait une
stratégie complètement différent les
renforts ont été plus nombreux je
mâchais vous serez du front c'était une
énorme surprise que nous ayons réussi à
briser les défenses à lui manque
lang harrison ne s'attendait à cela et
ce fut une agréable aux grandes unités
est-ce qu'il gâche chuté entre temps les
troupes de leur chef savourer leur
succès une fois la ligne une banque
franchie il pouvait contempler une
avance de 8 km sur un front de 10 de
large
plus de 6000 soldats ennemis fait
prisonnier et encore plus de morts et de
blessés avec trois divisions allemandes
proches de la destruction
les pertes britanniques s'élevant
pourtant à 4000 hommes fiers de cette
victoire un triomphe selon les standards
de la grande guerre les allemands
étaient probablement mieux préparés que
brittany chaud et poursuivant le
valeureux car ces derniers avec les
beaux hôtels choir dans les premières 24
heures également
et si les chars avaient pénétré les
premières listes de défendre il n'avait
pas pour autant briser l isolement
il n'y avait pas non plus quand
britanniques perdaient leur les lignes
de communication salons des et les trous
est elle une anti fatigue
la nuit du 20 novembre vite une intense
activité dans chaque camp les allemands
étaient en train de vider cambrai de ses
soldats qu'ils s'envoyaient sur des
défenses improvisé du côté britannique
les troupes et est briefé pour le
lendemain tandis que les chars faisait
le plein de carburant se réarmaient et
se regroupaient sur les 374 qui avait
attaqué le premier jour seule la moitié
reste est opérationnel pour le jour
suivant
les allemands n'avaient pas vraiment
l'occasion au départ de stopper la vente
britannique
il se reposait énormément ce rallye
usain bolt était si forte à cet endroit
que les allemands n'avaient pas vu vt
foot de masse est beaucoup trop leur
confiance dans leur ligne de défense a
également contribué à regarder leur
contre attaque a stoppé le sport il
voulait laisser les alliés son spectre
est dans la ligne hindenburg crèche ce
qui leur a donné le temps de déployer
des renforts issus d'autres zones
après le succès du premier jour la nuit
qui suivit fut une déception qui se
poursuivit toute la journée les attaques
britanniques eurent lieu sur les deux
points qui avait été désignée
précédemment sur la gauche
les riders trouvèrent fléquières
abandonné par les allemands mais une
ligne qui partait de quentin jusqu'à
bourlon en passant par fontaine était
solidement tenue ne général art peuple
attend dit pas les douze chars qui lui
était alloué et fit marche et ses
troupes a découvert les cornemuses en
avant là où aurait dû se trouver les
chars
ils furent prises immédiatement sur le
feu de l'artillerie est resté repérés
jusqu'à l'arrivée des chars
en une heure les allemands pierre
bouteyre de quentin et 400 d'entre eux
fait prisonnier mais les bonnes
nouvelles s'arrêter là les chars avaient
réussi à repousser les allemands jusque
dans le bois de bourlon mais ne pouvait
pas y pénétrer et sans eux
l'infanterie ne pouvait pas progressé
la seconde attaque britannique près de
manière ne permit de prendre qu'un peu
de terrain les chars arrivèrent
tardivement les allemands avaient eu le
temps de renforcer leur défense
leurs mitrailleuses étaient alimentés en
munitions perforantes
et bien que les chartistes encaissé un
nombre impressionnant de balles il ne
pouvait pas non plus sur vivre
indéfiniment ses blindages pouvait
protéger les équipages victimes d'armes
légères mais comme vous voyez sur les
dégâts causés ici munitions plus grosse
du canon antichar n'est plus qu'a livré
le but d'artillerie travers simplement
le compartiment par exemple les
attaquants voit ici qui ont été causés
par les mitrailleuses ont simplement
posté la carlingue cents à traverser
alors qu'ici les plaques de blindage ont
été perforés le charrette et perd ses
parents par et ici on peut voir à
travers les allemands s'étaient remis du
choc de la veille il y avait fait
évoluer leurs méthodes pour affronter
les attaques de chars
le second jour de la taxe sur cambrai
est à dire le 21 novembre 1916 tchaman
les allemands qui avaient entendu parler
d' attaque massive de chat c'est en est
à portée des munitions perforant sa mort
si certaines de ces balles trouvées
percer le blindage des chapelets et en
attaque mais la meilleure arme qui
disposait à l'encontre de ces derniers
mais qui n'était autre qu'un canon de
campagne de 77 millions
monté sur un camion ou parfois une
carriole tirée par un dose était que
lorsque l'on tirait sur l'aiguillé
retire avec ce qu'on avait sous la main
on pouvait même tirer les briques car il
fallait que quelques fleurs est alors
ont chargé les canons avec lui ce qu'on
trouvait et on faisait feu en profitant
de la mauvaise visibilité des équipages
de chat les fantassins allemands sont
approchés jusqu'à jeter un sac une
demi-douzaine de grenade dans les
chenilles pour les faire sauter les tirs
de char eux ne devenait réellement
précis que lorsqu'il était à l'arrêt
lorsque le char est en mouvement les le
brassin des riches n'étaient que l'on ne
voyait rien à travers les lunettes de
visée dont on voit ici le classement
perte de temps à combrée il ya plus de
chars en pagne que de chars détruits par
l'ennemi
ceci n'est guère surprenant avec ses 28
ans j'étais beaucoup trop lourd pour son
moteur sa transmission et sa suspension
n'importe quel véhicule et moderne où le
moteur est complètement séparé du raid
les pages ici et oui membres d'équipage
travail autour du moteur dans des
conditions vraiment primitive des
températures terrifiante est atteinte à
cause du moteur ospreys dont les fumées
d'échappement courait vers le toit à
travers le compartiment le niveau de
bruit et effrayant
or que je suis quelqu'un me crie est à
l'oreille l'entendait pas et les plaques
de blindage était si mal a semblé qu'un
tir de mitrailleuse concentré pourrait
s'introduire à la moindre faille et
faire pénétrer chef de clan les faits vu
de l'intérieur était que l'obscurité du
compartiment était soudainement et de
santé des bassins versants la carlingue
j'ai crié tu es jolie les brûlant enfin
il y avait le monoxyde de carbone le pot
d'échappement libérée du magnifique de
carbone dès qu'il y ait des fumées
d'échappement en veille s'est rapidement
le compartiment de combat après à peine
quatre ou cinq heures de combat
l'équipage de huit hommes étaient
complètement épuisé ou même fortement
malade une règle statistiques voulait
que les équipages de charles disponibles
soit réduite de moitié à chaque journée
d'engagement sans tenir compte des
pertes dues à l'ennemi
ce qui fait qu'au bout de trois jours
n'y avait théoriquement plus de charny
d'équipage en état de combat bien que ce
chiffre puisse provenir à la hausse
après quelques jours de repos le soir du
21 novembre le maréchal haig dû prendre
une décision difficile
la carte des chars avaient été jouées
avec l l'élément de surprise cela
valait-il la peine de continuer lors de
la planification il avait indiqué qu'il
ferait une revue de la situation après
48 heures et qu'il retirerait ses
troupes si celle-ci piétiner
ceux ci étaient directement à
l'attention des politiciens de londres
les attaques constantes et inutile de
passion des belles et de la somme
n'aurait pas lieu à nouveau
mais comment pouvait-il rom son attaque
après le triomphe du premier jour où
était sa percée si longtemps anticipée
une chose était sûre l'armée allemande
avait été affaiblie ce qui valait la
peine d'une seconde tentative
d'augmenter ses chances il puisa des
troupes fraîches dans les rangs de la
troisième armée il attaqué au seul
endroit digne d'intérêt
le bois de bourlon la vaine attaque du
flanc droit serait abandonné mais la
décision prise le lendemain le 22
novembre déboucha sur des préparatifs un
tir de barrage vous planifiez des
troupes fraîches acheminer le parc des
charges vidé de ses équipages et mécano
il y avait également des signes de
préparation chez les allemands une
centaine d'hommes du si force est l'un
d'eux tenait fontaine une position très
exposé ils firent l'objet d'une attaque
surprise des allemands et leur chef
georges harper encore une fois refusé de
leur envoyer de l'aide
la position peu et facilement être prise
au lendemain disait-il
lsi forces se repliaient
la bataille pour le bois le village de
bourlon fit rage durant cinq jours du 23
au 27 novembre
le premier jour la 40e division
attaquant samples écopé en brillamment à
vingt ou trente chats réussit à pendant
la plus grande partie du bois au prix de
lourdes pertes avoisinant les quatre
mille hommes en deux jours avec l'appui
de quelques chars des éléments de la
division essayèrent de contourner le
bois pour prendre pied en lisière du
village
mais les chars étaient trop peu nombreux
et les faisait allemand trop intense
pour qu'ils puissent thoniers le to fit
aggravée par l'échec de la 36e division
sur leur flanc gauche qui ne parvint pas
à progresser le long du canal du nord ce
qui les exposent à au feu de l'ennemi
sur leurs flancs et leur arrière sur la
droite
les choses ne s'arrangeaient pas non
plus la 51e division de harper ne pas va
pas apprendre fontaine une fois de plus
trop en arrière des chars qui avait
pourtant réussi à entrer dans le village
est ce si dur se replier faute d'appui
de leur infanterie harper
inexplicablement attaque avec seulement
deux bataillons alors qu'il en avait
quatre de plus à sa disposition
il existe un grand débat historique sur
la pertinence des décisions gérard peur
à cette période mais lui faut c'est sûr
c'est peut-être une chance qui n'est pas
engagé tous ces bataillons car le soir
du 27
il était absolument crucial de repousser
les aliments chauds qui avait avancé
jusqu'au bois du havre ac ou la division
d'élite de la garde remplaça les
écossais fatigué par la bataille et le
les combats les plus désespérés de toute
la bataille de cambrai eurent lieu
comprendre centaine alors que les gars
tentés de goûter puis le 9 bataillon
allemand
l'âge le 27 novembre
il devint évident que les britanniques
ne pouvait plus gagner la bataille
les allemands mais cette division sur la
faune de 13 kilomètres dans la zone de
fontaine bourlon et le canal du nord et
d'autres arrivées leur artillerie avait
réduit le bois de borloo en un amas de
troncs d'arbres dans les airs les
britanniques perdent est également le
royal charline qu on savait accomplira
est formidable en pilonnant les
positions allemandes au début de
l'attaqué mais le 23 novembre
le baron von richthofen était entré dans
la danse arrivant des flandres et leurs
ouailles à flins en corse avait perdu le
contrôle des cieux bien qu'il ait doublé
l'effectif de ses patrouilles
mais si les britanniques qui n'était pas
arrivé à briser la ligne de fond entre
borloo et son antenne voulait tenir
jusqu'aux premières neiges
les allemands eux ne l'entendaient pas
ainsi
lors d'une conférence qui a eu lieu le
27 novembre les officiellement présenté
leurs plans de contre attaque
un lot de noves très en colère il fut
lancé le lendemain avec 3d vision
allemande mettant la pression sur la
partie nord de l'île britannique
ceux-ci réussir à tenir mais là tu as
qu'il ait pris complètement pas surpris
puis celle du 30 novembre à 6h du matin
cette division frappe heurte à la base
des positions britanniques au sud est
leur intention était de remonter vers le
nord-est pour faire leur jonction avec
leur unité attaquante honor détruisant
les troupes britanniques au passage et
reprenant la majeure partie de la ligne
et dolbeau il y réussir preste
après leur avancée du 20 novembre les
britanniques n'avaient que peu fortifier
leurs positions les chefs des divisions
en place sur le canal saint quentin
avait observé rapporté d'activité
ennemies inhabituel mais le commandant
lui estimé que les allemands étaient
trop affaibli en manque de troupes
fraîches pour une attaque après cette
action reste sage
la première chose que devrait faire une
unité de sorte à ses peines et
consolider réussi et ce bonheur des
hommes sans s'épuiser
avec l'adrénaline qui les a mené toute
la journée et c'est pourquoi toutes les
a remis en ligne et d'acheminer ces
renforts aussi vite que possible pour
relever les trous elles sont et ce sont
ces renforts qui se fortifie la poly
darla k mai à cambrai était très
difficile d'amener des renforts
l' attaque allemande à soma les
britanniques plus que les britanniques
avait assommé les allemands le premier
jeu précédé de gaz d'obus explosifs et
de bombardements aériens des groupes de
combat léger rapide
armés de grenades et de pistolets
mitrailleurs de lance-flammes
déboulèrent à travers les lignes
ennemies et se retrouvèrent à mi-chemin
de leur objectif dès 9 heures le matin
le premier jour le charme népal a remis
des halles pour des formes de sommation
c'est pourquoi succèdent bataille avec
stéphanie fier comme une offense à pois
chiches force et les sans abri tout
simplement pas équipé pour vale une
bataille défense et c'était une sucre
attaques bien construites
les britanniques en mesure de résister
malgré la confusion le commandement
britannique et agite efficacement et
avec rapidité en début d'après midi deux
divisions et la cavalerie à pied
combattez pour reprendre le village de
gouzeaucourt le teint cops de sa propre
initiative avait rassemblé 63 machines
les avait envoyés vers la mitraille dans
la plus grande tradition militaire
après avoir progressé de 5 à 6 km et
fait plus de 4000 prisonniers
les allemands prévoyaient de renouveler
leurs attaques lendemain le 1er décembre
six divisions de les frapper à nouveau à
l'est et sur le flanc droit des
britanniques
l'assaut a été planifiée pour 9h30 du
matin mais les britanniques reprirent
l'initiative attaque en deux heures plus
tôt précédé de 16 chars les garder tous
faire la tacc principal des allemands et
bien que les britanniques aient perdu
manière et ne purent tenue villers
guislain après que les chars les prix
les allemands comme les britanniques
n'avaient pas réussi à tenir leur succès
de la première journée
les combats se poursuivirent sur
plusieurs jours en particulier dans la
zone de boer l'eau mais le 7 décembre
une forte neige convainquit les deux
camps d'abandonner la bataille de
cambrai reste aujourd'hui la première
bataille de chars de l'histoire ce ne
fut pas une bataille de chars contre xa
car en 1917
l'armée allemande n'en avait pas il
considérait l'utilisation de chars comme
une perte de temps et quand 20
ordinateurs d autres conséquences de la
bataille de cambrai a deux fils que les
allemands ont eu entre les mains un
grand nombre de chars britannique
abandonné tish avant d'une taxe et que
c'est la première fois ils ont été en
mesure de les rapatrier
ces cinq ans descend sharks étaient
entre les mains des allemands surtout
envoyait charleroi par chemin de fer
avec ses 50 chars ils ont remis retrouve
en état de combat
cambrai montra que correctement utilisé
les chars les coupes et les barbelés
franchir les tranchées détruire les
mitrailleuses et les bunkers
les chars permettait de réduire les
pertes de l'infanterie de manière
drastique et de donner plus de confiance
aux troupes d'assaut
la bataille de cambrai cependant montera
également les limites et les faiblesses
de ces engins il ne pouvait te crées
dans les bois par exemple et dans le
confinement d'une zone urbaine il
nécessitait la pluie de l'infanterie il
devait être protégé de l'artillerie et
des troupes qu'il est traqué il était
trop lent trop peu fiable et trop
épuisant par leurs équipages
deux tiers des 474 chars engagés dans la
bataille de cambrai furent perdues et le
temps corps perdu 1153 sommes sur un
total de 4 me de la guerre le chien
n'était pas un engin de percée de
courseulles et charlie et les français
développé pouvait s'être historique pour
l'action et la poursuite et mettre un
terme à l'affrontement par une guerre de
mobilité rétrospectivement je pense
qu'il était clair pour les généraux que
ce fut une bataille de transit il
s'entraînait pour les grandes batailles
et à l'est indubitablement avoir lieu
l'année suivante
mais c'est terminé leur rythmique de
combat expérimenté un peu la coopération
interarabe et trouver ce que les chars
au vph cher contre la ligne hindenburg
cambrai sont jaloux cours de la guerre
face au but mais cela relève de la
mythologie
c'est ce que les gens pensaient pouvoir
accomplir pour leur donna le pouvoir
politique de convaincre le gouvernement
d'expérimenter de nouveaux types de
formations division blindée georges
docteur etc
les charges jouèrent un rôle
intermittent mais vital dans la victoire
alliée de 1918 en particulier le 8 août
à amiens jour noir de l'armée allemande
les unités de chars britannique
commémore toujours ce 20 novembre 1917
en souvenir du jour où des hommes et ont
le courage d'essayer une arme nouvelle
et inconnue